we'll start with this from the daily
wires as a sold-out houston music
festival attended by an estimated 50 000
people
turned deadly on friday night after a
headliner began to perform
the associated press reported the crowd
gathered for the two-day event in nrg
park at astro
uh they suddenly surged toward the stage
during a performance by rapper travis
scott
and he was not just the performer at
this uh astroworld event this it's his
event he puts the event on i believe he
has an album named called astroworld so
this is this is his event that he puts
on
and um it says quote they started
surging towards the stage squeezing fans
so tightly together that they could not
breathe or move their arms and killing
eight people in the chaos
hospitalizing several others according
to the outlet as a timer clicked down to
start the performance
the crowd pushed forward
nick johnson a high school student who
attended the concert told the ap
everyone was passing out around you
everyone was trying to help each other
but you couldn't move you couldn't do
anything you can't even pick your arms
up it just got worse and worse now keep
in mind
eight people
and i mean this is this is a been a
pretty big story in the news i don't
know how it's not a bigger story than
it's being treated
eight people
mostly kids
died at a concert
but remember
you know uh
prior to to this
what i think was considered the
deadliest and most um catastrophic music
festival ever was woodstock 99.
um
and and in that i i believe that was
like a two or three day festival there
was 100 200 000 people there and three
or four people died and it was a big
deal at the time i can remember it
distinctly
you have three or four deaths with that
many people this is eight people
in a crowd of fifty thousand
in a span of a couple hours died
uh officials called off the event about
40 minutes after law enforcement
observed concerts concert goers going
down
authorities said a mass casualty
incident had occurred at 9 38 p.m
according to houston chronicle concert
attendee said scott appeared to play his
whole set and finished at 10 15 p.m
and travis scott is uh the boyfriend or
whatever i don't think they're married
of kylie jenner one of the
kardashians
um
there there's
there are a lot of weird reports coming
out of this concert and i i don't know
how much of it is true or not
one thing that you heard early on
kind of the rumor circulating online is
that people were being injected with
some unknown substance and this has been
at least partially confirmed there was
there was a security guard
who was briefly
rendered unconscious after feeling a
prick
on his neck
and then he was they woke him up and
they found markings where he had been
injected by somebody
and there were also reports of
many uh at least several people going
into cardiac arrest
it's not clear if that happened during
this surge or before it or if it had
something to do with what sparked it to
begin with
we had people being injected with drugs
apparently other people being trampled
to death
and the videos that you see online now
and i'm not going to play them you can
go you can go find these videos there's
many of them circulating
travis scott
is up there
continuing the performance
now early on i read reports saying that
he stopped he stopped multiple times to
try to tell the crowd to back up that
was the report anyway that's the claim i
have not seen any videos
of travis scott stopping the concert
doesn't mean he didn't do it i haven't
seen those videos
the videos i've seen
show travis scott up on the stage while
there are kids collapsing all around and
medics rushing into the crowd and he's
he's continuing to perform
but now he says that he's very upset
about it and uh and he put out a kind of
a statement on instagram
the next day talking about how
devastated he is and uh
i don't know you
watch this and tell me if you find it to
be sincere
i just want to send out prayers to the
to the ones that was lost last night
we're actually working right now
to identify the families
so we can help assist them through this
tough time you know my fans my fans like
my fans really mean the world to me and
i always just really want to leave them
with a positive experience
anytime i can make out
you know anything that's going on you
know you know how to stop the show and
you know help them get the help they
need you know um
i could just never imagine the severity
of the situation
yeah i find that his reaction
somewhat unsettling i i don't really
eight people just died in front of you
man at your concert
eight kids were just trampled to death
and this is this is his reaction it
sounds like he's
you know it's it sounds like the kind of
statement that you have if uh if you had
to cancel the concert or something
because something happened
and people were you know and you had to
issue a bunch of refunds and people were
inconvenienced
and so i could see that
yeah really really sorry about that you
know really really really unfortunate
when i watch that especially as he's
right he's not taking his hands off his
head the entire time that's kind of a
tell also that someone's not being
entirely sincere
they keep rubbing their face and
everything so he's got all those tells
but it's it's and he does it in black
and white he takes the time to change
the filter on it to make it black and
white this is someone who seems to me
trying to seem
devastated and saying that they're
devastated but doesn't really seem that
way to me
one thing you have to
remember about travis scott some
background on this guy
is that he has a history of riling up
the crowd at his concerts
intentionally encouraging them to rush
through security barricades now i don't
know if he did that during this concert
but he has a history of doing that
i've read some accounts from security
guards who've worked travis scott
concerts
and how he'll kind of turn against them
during the concert and encourage fans to
bum rush them
there's another video very disturbing
from a few years ago where where he was
uh travis scott was crowd surfing
and some kid in the he looked like he
was 14 or 15 years old maybe younger
some kid grabs his shoe i don't know if
intentionally or not and then travis
scott
loses his mind on this kid and starts
calling for the crowd to you know f him
up and to beat the kid up for taking his
shoe
enlisting a crowd of people who many of
them already drunk on drugs
they're kind of out of their minds
because that's that's the environment at
these kinds of concerts
it's an environment
intentionally designed to make people
sort of lose their senses
and he's sicking this this mob on this
kid because it took a shoe meanwhile i'm
sure this guy has 500 pairs of shoes at
his house
along with a couple dozen backstage for
all of his outfit changes wardrobe
changes that's the kind of guy he is
um
which means i put all that together and
i put this on him i don't know how
i put this on him
at least to the extent that you blame
alec baldwin
for shooting the cinematographer
i mean it wasn't just his fault or other
people involved
but you're the one holding the gun
and you didn't check it and so this
falls on you travis scott this is your
concert
it's up to me you to make sure
everything is safe
at the very least
if eight people die it means that this
was a massive
failure
in planning and logistics and making
sure you had enough security there
and that goes to you
you throw an event and eight people die
because
at a minimum because because of poor
planning
yeah this guy should be arrested and
charged already
shouldn't even be a discussion
and then you add into that all the you
see some of the the pictures from the
from the event and you hear some of the
accounts and there's a lot of just weird
satanic imagery everywhere
i was listening to one account from a
girl that was there saying that it was
just and she's not
she said that she's not religious but it
felt weird and satanic even to her even
the kind of music they were playing
and all of this stuff is designed to
make as i said it kind of makes people
lose
their senses lose their mind in a
certain way
and it's designed to have that effect
[Music]
and then you add in all the drugs and
everything even more so
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt well show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content